final question
it's fascinating when you read some of
the earlier philanthropist like the
gospel of wealth by Carnegie and folks
who wrote something that sounds so
different on what people say today with
some notable exceptions and what they
write is when they have accumulated
capital and they've been incredibly
successful as capitalist it's not their
money they say we're conduits we have
had special skills and gifts that
allowed us to create great wealth and so
what our duty is to return it back to
society yet for a lot of people in this
particular moment which is also a sort
of a new Gilded Age people say it's my
life I should be able to do what I want
with it and what do you think of that of
that conversation because you are
engaged in a certain or at least some
conversation with great wealth yeah I I
just think that you know I think far too
much in art in the United States today
people think about themselves and think
about things that I have to me there
Matt and yes you've earned the money but
but think about community and think
about other people and think beyond
yourself and how can you make a
difference in the world I mean how could
how can you and you know there's just
there's so much that needs doing and you
have the means to do it and you have the
intelligence to that when you get out
when you graduate you go out you can use
your intelligence to make something
great happen and it doesn't have to be
in terms of money and how much you make
you can also be in the nonprofit world
or you can make money and give it away
but I think far too many people I think
of it as being selfish and instead of
giving it away I just I wanted to cite
one quote sure which is Katharine Graham
who said to love what you do and know
that it matters what could be more fun
and
she did it when she broke the glass
ceiling and about what really inspire
you know her being in the publishing
world when she never thought she could
do it and wasn't necessarily about
philanthropy but i think you know to
love what you do and know that it
matters what could be more fun and
philanthropy is is is really fun it's
hard work and if you get it in a big way
you've got to evaluate and assess and do
all those things but it's fun and think
that that way